Film Courage: What do you think makes a boring
character to you?
West Liang: I think a character with no inner
life.
I think for me if some character has some
inner life (if that makes sense).
Whether that inner life is subtext or whether
that inner life is in conflict with his public
life or her public life.
That’s interesting to me.
I think it really depends on the kind of story
that it is.
To make the comparison of making a meal.
I think every meal is different and it commands
a different kind of ingredient.
I certainly don’t feel like I have all the
answers by any means.
For me, I’m still trying to figure things
out on my own.
And I’m trying to figure things out based
on my own kind of sensibilities, my own way
of writing.
I think having some kind of life…what about
you?
Film Courage: I’m even thinking of a movie
that was light and fluffy like LEGALLY BLOND.
It was still interesting (her character).
You want to see her [win].
She doesn’t get easily taken aback by all
these jabs that are thrown her way.
And you’re like “Wow, that’s kind of
interesting?”
She keeps being light, bubbly and happy when
most people would be giving them [her detractors]
the middle finger after awhile, you know?
[Laughs].
And so [as the viewer] you’re like “Wow?
I find her interesting.”
That’s kind of a light and fun film but
there is still a message behind it.
It’s a studio film that wasn’t boring.
It was interesting enough to keep my attention
and I’m sure a lot of other people’s,
as well.
West Liang: I mean it’s an incredibly crafted
screenplay.
On a plot level in terms of where things happen
in terms of having this first kind of pre-life
and how that changes and inciting incidents
and all that stuff.
But you look at her character [Reese Witherspoon
as Elle] and she’s battling again expectations
of her, that people have with who she might
be and what her inner life might be.
There are plot-driven stories and there are
character-driven stories and I think they
sort of overlap in a lot of areas, but generally
speaking if you’re talking about a character
for me, if there is something about that character
that tells me that either that person isn’t
telling everything about his life or her life.
Or there is something about that person where
what he or she is doing in front of people
is different from what they’re doing behind-the-scenes,
for me that’s interesting.